il y a les skieurs qui terminent leur
journée à la tombée de la nuit
il ya ceux qui n'attendent que cela on
chausse les raquettes dans la pénombre
il est 17 heures sous les flocons un peu
plus serré en milieu forestier
c'est parti a priori une randonnée en
raquettes classique avec les premières
cibles en fête pascale van ling emmène
ses clients au coeur de la nuit avec de
bonnes raisons de le faire là parfois
non il arrive qu'on comprend la cheville
et c'est une autre approche de la
montagne la montagne a retrouvé son
calme
les remontées mécaniques ce soit en
éteinte plus de bruit en plus ce soir
les flocons des neiges de neige et la
neige poudreuse amortissent chaque bruit
de pas donc c'est sympa de marché dans
cette ambiance juste le crissement de la
poudreuse sous les raquettes
quelques cris lorsque long dévale un
champ de neige vierge et sous une très
timide ce soir là le guide se transforme
en conteur les gens de fait de brigands
de la montagne un coup dans ce vacarme
la montagne s'ouvre aux gothiques
village lébou de glaciers le cerac
desrochers question plombé le village
tombe est un artiste et dernière et pour
réchauffer les randonneurs la coulée de
génie
le génépi ça c'était vraiment ce qui à
mes yeux j'aime bien la solitude j'aime
bien
la nature je suis un peu un peu mystique
comme ça c'est relaxant c'est vraiment
bien trois heures de randonnée
et puis s'en vont le groupe redescend
derniers instants de solitude au milieu
des sapins avant de retrouver les
lumières de la station